بالفعل محمد هو قصف مدفعي مستمر ومتواصل
والقصف المدفعي استهدف منزلا لعائله
القرناوي في مخيم المغازي وا وصل الى هنا
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى ع شهداء جراء هذا
القصف المدفعي القصف المدفعي مستمر
ومتواصل على مدار اللحظه منذ منذ صباح هذا
اليوم ونحن نستمع الى اصواط الانفجارات
الشديده الناجمه عن قصف الاليات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه المتمركزه على الحدود الشرقيه
لمنازل المدنيين الفلسطينيين جل ما يتم
استهدافه هي منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه حتى ان
قذائف المدفعيه الاسرائيليه باتت تصل الى
مديات ابعد الى منطقه الزوايده حيث ايضا
اصيب اربعه فلسطينيين جراء استهداف
الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه المتمركزه
على الحدود الشرقيه ايضا هذه المنطقه
واستهدفت منزلا واصيب اربعه فلسطينيين تم
نقلهم الى هنا الى مستشفى الشهداء الاقصى
ايضا هناك هدافين على الاقل في مخيم
النصيرات حيث استهدفت ايضا المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه منزلا في شارع المحكمه في على
مدخل مخيم النصيرات ونقل الى مستشفى
العوده في المخيم ايضا عدد من الاصابات
ايضا هناك غاره في مخيم النصيرات في بلوك
سي الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قصفت
هدفا هناك وحتى الان لم نتبين طبيعه هذا
الهدف وبالتالي خلال الساعه الماضيه
والدقائق القليله الماضيه الاستهدافات
باتت مكثفه في المنطقه الوسطى الجيش
الاسرائيلي على ما يبدو يكثف ويعود لتكثيف
عملياته في هذه المنطقه التي تشهد عمليات
توغل حتى الان من شرق مخيم البريج وتقدمت
الدبابات الاسرائيليه الى نحو 2 م من هذه
المنطقه ما زالت في مناطق مفتوحه مناطق لا
يوجد فيها كثافه سكانيه عاليه الناس نزحت
من هذه المناطق لا سما وانها قريبه من
السياج الفاصل لكن المحور الجديد وهو ربما
المحور الاخطر والذي باتت ايضا الدبابات
الاسرائيليه التي تتقدم شيئا فشيئا من
مفترق الشهداء باتجاه مدخل مخيم البريج
بالتالي هي تقصف كل ما هو متواجد امامها
سواء على يمينها او على يسارها على يسارها
هو مخيم البريج ومنطقه جحر الديك وعلى
يمينها هي المناطق الموجوده في شمال مخيم
النصيرات وايضا مخيم النصيرات وكلها مناطق
ماهوله بالسكان وبالتالي هناك اعداد من
الاصابات حتى الان لم تستطع سيارات
الاسعاف الوصول اليها وعمليات التنشيط لم
تستطع ان تقوم بها طواقم الدفاع المدني
وطواقم الاسعاف في تلك المناطق وبالتالي
حتى الان يمكن القول ان هذا التطور هو
التطور اللافت التطور الابرز في الساعات
الماضيه لا سما وان وصول الدبابات
الاسرائيليه الى مدخل مخيم البريج
بالتاكيد
سيكون بالتاكيد سيكون صعبا لا سما وان
الدخول والخروج من المخيم صعب كان بسبب
استمرار عمليات القصف لكنها ستكون هذه
الدبابات الان قريبه جدا من مخيم النصيرات
ومن المناطق الشماليه لهذا المخيم بالتالي
التطورات متسارعه سواء هنا في المنطقه
الوسطى سواء في خانيونس سواء في رفح او
حتى في غزه والشمال كلها قصف اسرائيلي
مستمر ومتواصل على كل هذه المناطق